déjà confrontés à des risques
épidémiques mais jamais avec une telle
violence et pour une durée aussi longue
puisque la france comme ses pays voisins
on n'est pas encore quitte avec le virus
cela veut dire qu'il a fallu pouvoir
apporter des réponses rapides et
adaptées gestion de crise dans un
contexte scientifique qui a évolué mais
cela signifie aussi maintenir un effort
considérable dans la durée pour tous
ceux qui sont confrontés directement à
la gestion de la crise et en particulier
les soignants mais aussi pour tous les
français nous avons à ce stade un
premier regard rétrospectif a porté sur
ce qui a été fait conformément à l'objet
de notre mission mais il est clair que
les tendances actuelles d'évolution est
ce qu'on peut attendre dur confinement
vont aussi nous occuper aujourd'hui
alors monsieur le ministre avant de
débuter notre audition je vais vous
demander de prêter serment en effet
l'article 6 de leur donnant du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission denquête de prêter serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité rien que
la vérité
je vais donc vous demander de lever la
main droite et de dire je le jure ces
mesures
merci beaucoup je vous rappelle que
cette audition et public elle est donc
diffusé en direct puis consultables aux
vidéos elle fera également l'objet d'un
compte rendu écrit qui sera publié ce
ministre pour débuter cette audition je
vous propose est de commencer par un
propos liminaire avant que nous
débutions les questions ce ministre
c'est à vous monsieur le président je
remercie monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
n'allons pas parler ensemble d'un sujet
passé date est terminée hélas si des
questions légitimes se posent sur les
décisions qui ont été prises depuis
l'apparition du corona virus sur notre
territoire
chacun doit garder à l'esprit que
l'heure est toujours à la lutte contre
le virus et pas aux conclusions
définitives avant toute chose j'aimerais
rendre hommage à celles et ceux qui font
face à cette crise dans nos hôpitaux
dans nos ehpad en ville sans oublier
bien sûr les professionnels du domicile
et tous ceux qui permettent à la france
de résister aux chocs et de tenir je
vais aussi rendre hommage et dire toute
ma gratitude
vos agents des administrations centrales
les agences régionales de santé et de
tous les services de l'état
leur engagement est exceptionnel et
chaque jour ils forcent l'admiration
cette crise sanitaire je la vis depuis
ma prise de fonction le 17 février
dernier j'ai été nommé ministre
alors que le virus circulait depuis peu
en france
il est alors plus de 70000 personnes
infectées à travers le monde dont un
millier hors de chine
en franchissant les portes du ministère
je n'ignorais et donc pas les risques
associés à cette épidémie sans pour
autant m'attendre à son évolution en
pandémie le 11 mars 2020 nous allons
parler ensemble des choix qui ont été
faits des choix difficiles lourds
souvent dans l'urgence à agir dans
l'urgence ne veut pas dire agir avec
précipitation mais agir alors même que
certaines inconnues persistent
je viens devant vous avec humilité nous
traversons une période qui demande aux
politiques qui a tout ceux qui se
prononcent sur l'action publique
beaucoup d'humilité je viens pas non
plus partager une opinion je viens
décrypter avec vous les chemins que nous
avons empruntée depuis le premier jour
dans un contexte d'incertitude jamais
égalé dans notre histoire contemporaine
un contexte dans lequel il s'est agi
d'apporter des réponses à des problèmes
qui se sont présentés devant nous chaque
jour quand surgit un événement comme
celui-ci les avis se multiplient les
opinions se juxtaposent et les jugements
sont vendus aussi vite qu'ils peuvent
être rencontrés depuis que genre dos et
mon costume de ministre je me suis
efforcé d'écouté faire le tri entre le
bon grain et l'ivraie a été mon
quotidien tandis qu'au même moment où
les français attendent et bien sûr des
réponses fermes dans une crise comme
celle que nous traversons les
connaissances d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas
celles juillet
les connaissances évoluent la science
évolue seul le bon sens est immuable a
jamais figé dans l'esprit de ceux qui
s'en réclament à tout va il pourrait
être tentant de lire les stratégies
d'hier à l'aune des connaissances
d'aujourd'hui
je vous demande donc de tenir compte du
caractère évolutif de ses connaissances
nous apprenons tous les jours en même
temps que nous agissons de la même
manière le temps politique n'est pas le
temps scientifique et cette donnée ne
doit pas échapper aux échanges que nous
aurons rechercher la vérité à la lumière
des faits
c'est ce à quoi nous nous attelons
aujourd'hui je ne doute pas que cet
exercice servira autant la justesse du
regard que nous portons sur le passé
récent que l'efficacité de l'action que
nous menons aujourd'hui encore contre
l'épidémie
l'information judiciaire sur la gestion
ministérielle de la crise due qu'au bout
de dix neuf permettra également de
rendre compte de cette action et je
tenais le rappeler vous l'aurez compris
ma mission elle est de piloter la
réponse à la crise la crise d'hier
la crise d'aujourd'hui mais aussi la
crise de demain je suis aujourd'hui
devant vous parce que nous devons toutes
et tous apprendre d'une crise qui a
placé la santé publique au coeur de nos
préoccupations
je suis devant vous parce que le
parlement doit être une force motrice
dans les politiques de protection et de
prévention
je suis là parce que je suis le ministre
des solidarités et de la santé à ce
poste depuis le premier jour j'ai
toujours agi et parler avec
responsabilité et en toute transparence
je ne choisirai pas une autre ligne
aujourd'hui devant vous je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre je
m'associe à vous s'agissant des
remerciements vous avez pu adressé en
particulier aux personnels soignants
dont on sait à quel point il est laid
sollicitée est disponible et courageux
et engagé depuis le début de set
depuis 2008 cette crise j'ai pour ma
part 4 4 questions à vous poser pour
débuter cet entretien une première
question pour permettre de planter entre
guillemets un peu le décor s'agissant de
l'état des lieux du des travaux qui ont
été menés depuis la première vague
quels enseignements quelles adaptations
at-on réalisés en termes de personnel de
l'île équipements de protection depuis
cette première vague puisque on entend
beaucoup de choses et je voudrais qu'on
puisse clarifier les choses sur les
travaux qui ont été mis en place depuis
depuis ce temps là une deuxième question
qui a beaucoup animé les débats de noé
des questions plutôt de notre commission
denquête c'est la particularité de la
prise en charge des personnes âgées plus
particulièrement dans les ehpad
certains ont certaines personnes on
sous-entend du ou affirmiez pour
certains et certaines peu nombreuses
mais ça a été le cas quand même donc
certaines auditions que certaines
personnes âgées n'avaient pas forcément
bénéficié de tous les soins de toutes
les prises en charge hospitalière qu'ils
auraient pu bénéficier en temps normal
j'aurais voulu avoir votre avis dessus 1
1 3e troisième question en troisième
point s'agissant de de santé publique
france et surtout de la réponse que nous
devons pouvoir apporter à cette crise
mais également aux éventuelles crises
avant
vous l'avez dit dans votre propos
liminaire nous chassent nous faisons
face à virus jusqu alors totalement
inconnu avec des modes de contamination
des modes de transmission des mots
d'évolution à ses fins totalement
inconnu jusqu alors et il faut faire il
faut savoir faire preuve de réactivité
de rapidité et d'adaptabilité alors même
que la science progresse au jour le jour
nous l'avons vu de lors de l'audition
avec eux avec l'ancien premier ministre
edouard philippe qui nous disait que si
nous avions pris en charge les patients
selon le le mode du plan pandémie
grippale nous n'aurions probablement pas
faire autant de tests voire même pas du
tout de tests dont qu'il a il faut
savoir évoluer avec avec la connaissance
scientifique et donc voir quel était
votre regard sur l'adaptabilité de notre
système et je sais que mon collègue
notre collègue jean pierre door sera
probablement attentifs à cette question
savoir quel est votre regard sur les
prusse qui ait été intégré dans santé
publique france et quel est l'avenir que
l'on peut donner à l'eprus quelle est la
visibilité que l'on peut donner à
l'eprus quand on savait que l'eprus
avait ce rôle de prévisibilité et puis
enfin dernière question on voir avec
vous qu'elle est aujourd'hui
la stratégie de déploiement des tests
antigénique qui sont manifestement en
cours de déploiement
mais quel est votre regard le nombre de
tests déployés quelle utilité qu'elle
quel service peuvent-ils nous rendre à
l'avenir dans cette période de
confinement et dancette nous l'espérons
tous ce futur période de déconfinement
je vous remercie monsieur le président
votre première question porte sur la
préparation du système de santé
depuis la première vague évidemment
alors même que la première vague n'était
pas terminée nous avons débuté un
réflexe un retour d'expérience pour
faire justement toute la lumière sur la
crise sanitaire sur les éléments en lien
avec le virus et la façon de répondre à
l'épidémie
dans notre pays nous l'apprend donc
initié dès le printemps il a donné lieu
à de nombreuses observations et à de
nombreuses démarches en vue de préparer
notre système de santé dans
l'éventualité d'une deuxième vague
je pourrais vous citer plusieurs
exemples ça peut être une réponse très
longue et je souhaite fermer réponse
peut-être course pour laisser chacun le
temps à chacun le temps de poser des
questions mais sachez par exemple qu'il
y à un guide de préparation des
réanimations qui a été élaboré avec les
professionnels de santé cet été je vous
donne un exemple concret initialement la
quasi totalité des patients en tout cas
de ce qui m'a été remonté et qui
présentait un ace des races et c'est à
dire un syndrome de détresse
respiratoire aiguë conséquences graves
d'une maladie à coronavirus et qui était
transféré en réanimation et être intubé
et ventilé c'est à dire qu'on est placée
en coma qu'ils avaient un tube dans les
poumons pour une respiration automatisés
progressivement les expertises en france
et dans le monde ont permis d'élaborer
d'autres méthodes de soin note visant
notamment à différer voire à éviter une
intubation puisque une intubation sur
des poumons fragiles
ça peut créer des dégâts et prolonger la
durée de l'animation voir créer des
séquelles importantes ainsi un certain
nombre de patients ont pu bénéficier de
ce qu'on appelle le petit flou c'est de
l'oxygène à 50 litres minute très fort
débit
qui est à livrer en continu aux patients
qui présentent des besoins d'oxygène
retardant ainsi une intubation
évidemment lorsqu'on fait ce constat là
ç'a un impact sur les prises en charge
d'abord parce qu'à saintes un certain
nombre de patients se oxygène à fort
débit n'ont pas forcément besoin d'être
dans un service de réanimation en propre
mais s'ils ont un monitorage cardiaque
et respiratoire fatale est par exemple
en soins intensifs
si vous a permis d'adapter des services
de soins intensifs pour pouvoir il ya
dressé des patients atteints de
différentes ont tous la fai a fait
office de recommandations élaborées avec
les professionnels par ailleurs sur les
retours d'expérience territoriaux chaque
agence régionale de santé a mis en place
une gouvernance territoriale tenant
compte d'un certain nombre de points
essentiels je peux vous en citer
quelques-uns
quelle place pour la démocratie
sanitaire c'est à dire comment intégrer
davantage les usagers du soin dans les
processus décisionnels ou d'informations
à l'échelle des territoires
comment mieux coordonner les relations
entre le monde hospitalier et le monde
de la médecine de ville pour être plus
réactifs éventuellement anticiper des
sorties d'hospitalisation ou retardé des
hospitalisations lorsqu'elles ne sont
pas indispensables qu'elles rappellent
relations également avec les élus
comment s'assurer j'imagine que j'aurai
une question sur ce sujet comment
s'assurer de la pleine coopération et la
peine mobilisation du secteur privé
autant que du secteur public
bref dé gouvernance territoriale mise en
place par les agressent par ailleurs
évidemment nous avons entamé la
reconstitution du stock national
d'équipement de protection et nous avons
eu l'occasion de communiquer en toute
transparence avec edouard philippe
lorsqu'il était premier ministre
déjà pour donner les objectifs et puis
ensuite avec jean castex l'actuel
premier ministre en conférence de presse
pour annoncer quel était l'état des
stocks en masque blouson sur blues angan
respirateur en médicaments de
réanimation et tout cela a été fait au
cours de l'été notamment le stock de
médicaments de réanimation les femmes et
aux médicaments qui sont nécessaires
pour maintenir quelqu'un en coma
lorsqu'il est un tuber en réanimation
ces médicaments qui étaient si précieux
si précieux et pour lequel nous avions
connu des en tout cas un minima déçu et
pendant la période de la première vague
quant à notre capacité à fournir
suffisamment
et donc ces stocks ont été reconstitués
en même temps que les activités
chirurgicales reprenait progressivement
au cours de l'été dans nos hôpitaux
et ça ça une nécessité évidemment un
gros travail et puis toute la question
du mode la mobilisation des ressources
humaines qui est au coeur du sujet de la
prise en charge de la deuxième vague
puisqu'il n'y a pas de service de
réanimation supplémentaires ou de lits
de soins intensifs supplémentaires si
nous n'avons pas de personnel capable
d'aller donner des soins de qualité
spécifique dans les services ce que me
disait une équipe i hier c'est que en
réanimation à corbeil essonnes il
m'expliquait que par exemple lorsqu'un
patient étant sdr intubé et ventilé il
faut parfois le maître en décubitus
ventral s'est déroulé sur le ventre et
puis ensuite leur mettre sur le dos et
le remettre sur levante plusieurs fois
par jour et que cela nécessite une
technicité qu'un soignants qui n'a pas
connu cela qu'il n'a pas été formé et
tan tan de faire par ailleurs vous avez
des patients qui sont physiquement c'est
à dire une circulation extracorporelle
c'est les formes les plus graves et les
gros nécessite une technicité très
particulière tant médicales que
paramédical bref il a fallu former des
soignants et ce sont les hôpitaux les
universités qui se sont chargés de
lancer des programmes de formation dans
le territoire de belfort ou encore à
grenoble
j'ai assisté à des séances de formation
par simulation sur mannequins de
patients intubés est ventilé en
décubitus ventral par exemple qui ont
permis de former des dizaines des
centaines d'infirmiers et
d'aides-soignants pour qu'ils puissent
prêter main forte le bon ordre du dans
les services de réanimation et vous le
savez hélas on ne peut pas former de
réanimateurs en trois mois un élément
six mois c'est plutôt 10 à 12 ans et
donc les il a fallu je dirais permettre
deux gradés de monter en compétences un
certain nombre de soignants pour prêter
main forte à leurs collègues bac je ne
vais pas vous faire tout l'article sur
ce sujet mais sachez que c'est vraiment
le sujet aujourd'hui l'enjeu majeur pour
nous que d'être capable de mobiliser des
professionnels de santé supplémentaires
et nous avons mis en place également des
cibles de soutien psychologique guitare
sur votre deuxième question la prise en
charge des personnes âgées notamment en
ehpad
si je la comprends bien c'est est ce que
si je résumais et grossistes et votre
votre question vous me posez là qu'ils
ont savouré ce qu'on s'est bien occupé
des personnes âgées dans la crise
épidémique ou est ce qu'on les ont été
laissés de côté monsieur le
président sachez que tout a été fait
pour offrir les meilleurs soins de
meilleure qualité possible dans le
contexte difficile que nous connaissions
à toute personne quel que soit son âge à
sa condition physique sa condition
sociale
évidemment c'est à dire le principe même
du serment d'hippocrate
il a fallu organiser des filières de
prise en charge très proche entre les
ehpad qui accueillent des personnes
âgées en situation de perte d'autonomie
et les hôpitaux
nous avons développé des services
hospitaliers dans le secteur public et
privé
quasiment spécialisée dans l'accueil de
patients qu'ovide issus des ehpad
il a fallu également développer la
gouvernance médicale dans les ehpad
pourra faire intervenir
l'hospitalisation à domicile dans
l'ensemble des ehpad à intervenir de la
médecine de ville pouvoir voir des
protocoles et que les samu dans les
ehpad pour pouvoir intervenir partout
c'était nécessaire et faire en sorte que
chacun puisse avoir des soins
ensuite c'est comme il en va du coc vide
comme d'autres pathologies
il ya des personnes qui sont en état de
santé grave et pour lesquels un
transfert en réanimation et décidé
compte tenu à la fois la sévérité de la
maladie et à la fois de la condition
physique de la personne qui laisse
présager que une sortie de l'animation
sera possible et il ya des personnes qui
sont dans un état physique préexistants
tellement grave que les réanimations ne
prennent pas forcément la décision
d'aller intubé et ventilé cette personne
parce qu'ils savent qu'il ya 100 % du
risque que cela se traduise par un décès
dans des conditions qui sont parfois
encore plus difficile raisons pour
lesquelles nous avions 6 elle nous avons
sollicité la société française de
gériatrie notamment pour qu'elles
formulent des recommandations de prise
en charge et d'accompagnement
les derniers moments de la vie des
personnes les plus âgées qui ne pouvait
pas leur l'animation encore une fois que
je le dis c'est une en bas du dos vite
comme pour d'autres pathologies la
jemaye de seconde ma blouse de
neurologues
lorsque j'ai travaillé dans un service
d' unité neurovasculaire qui prenait en
charge des patients atteints d'avc et
satin patient qui était transférable et
transféré en réanimation lorsqu'il
s'aggravait et d'autres patients qui
étaient accompagnés par ce qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas supporter une animation
votre troisième question elle portait
sur santé santé publique france
alors vous avez démarré parce par santé
publique france mais a finalement on
m'avait posé plutôt la question sur les
prix et moins sur le fonctionnement
public france que sur la disparition en
tout cas là la phagocytose si je puis me
permettre
de l'eprus par santé publique france
était un texte de loi qui a été votée me
semble-t-il en 2014 ou 2015 il a vu le
rapport 2007
je croyais être déjà parlementaire
lorsque ça va être les faits ce n'était
pas le cas en 2007 j'étais plutôt en
blouse blanche en train de finir mon
internat probablement mais je sais que
le député jean-pierre door a émis des
propositions et a fait des rapports de
précieux sur le sujet vous dire d'abord
que santé publique france a répondu à sa
mission au niveau national et au niveau
régional en terre de contact racing et
notamment sur les clusters qu' il est
très compliqué pour être tout à fait
franc avec vous ne songez pas le choix
je suis sous serment
il est très compliqué de faire et taxes
complet et détaillé du fonctionnement
d'une structure en cas de crise tant
dans la crise parce que vous ne pouvez
pas mobilisé des équipes qui sont déjà
mobilisés évidemment je salue les
équipes de santé publique france qui
n'ont pas eu d'été et qui continuent de
travailler d'arrache-pied au quotidien
mais il faudra tirer toutes les
conséquences évidemment tirer les leçons
de ce qui s'est passé notamment sur la
gestion logistique d'un certain nombre
de stocks qui met d'ailleurs il m'a été
donné de diligenter une mission
d'inspection de des affaires sociales et
mission igas pendant la crise sur la
question de la logistique de certains
stocks au sein de sps parce qu'il faut
pouvoir comprendre et s'améliorer et ne
pas attendre la fin d'une crise
évidemment pour changer ce qui doit
l'être
donc j'aurai texte complet qu'on suivra
et vos travaux parlementaires seront
extrêmement utiles
est-ce qu'il faut identifier une
structure ad-hoc comme c'était le cas
donc avant 2007
ou est-ce qu'il faut modifier certaines
certains de façon de fonctionner nous
verrons enfin votre dernière question
porte sur une actualité brûlante celle
des tests anti janyk les tests
antigénique ont fait leur apparition
assez récemment et j'ai saisi à
plusieurs reprises la haute autorité de
santé cette instance scientifique chargé
de nous guider dans les décisions de
politique publique sanitaire afin
qu'elles émettent des recommandations
sur l'usagé ces tests antigénique je
rappelle pour ceux qui ne le
connaîtraient pas que le test en
nick procède du même mécanisme qu'un
test par pcr c'est-à-dire un écho dans
un égout visionnage naso pharyngé mais
qu'ensuite au lieu d'envoyer les
coutrillons dans un laboratoire
qu'ils soient techniques et sur
plateformes pc l'air ce qui peut prendre
un certain temps est directement
traitées par l'opérateur pour pouvoir
avoir un résultat de l'ordre de 15 à 20
minutes avec un petit bâton rouge qui
apparaît lorsque le patient est positif
oco vide ce test présente donc
l'avantagé évident d'être utilisable par
tous rapidement avec des résultats
rapides il présente en revanche une
moindre qualité en termes de sensibilité
c'est à dire hey capacité à
diagnostiquer quelqu'un positif surtout
chez des personnes asymptomatiques
pourquoi j'ai saisi la haute autorité de
santé sur ces deux sujets des patients
asymptomatiques est symptomatique haute
autorité de santé a remis deux
recommandations
une qui qui reconnaît l usage du test
antigénique en dépistage c'est à dire en
population asymptomatiques ce que nous
faisons dans les universités dans les
ehpad auprès des personnels soignants
dans les aéroports dans les ports dans
les gares et que nous allons multiplier
démultiplié sur tout le territoire dans
les jours et les semaines à venir et
d'autre part un intérêt chez les
patients symptomatiques en diagnostics
individuels où la sensibilité est bonne
mais la spécificité excellente et ça
permet de guider les conduites
diagnostic et ses tests antigénique sont
désormais autorisées j'en ai signé
l'arrêté il ya quelques jours pour une
utilisation en médecine de ville en
pharmacie d'officine ou par des
infirmiers infirmières libérales mais
également par d'autres professionnels de
santé dont la liste sera amené à évoluer
en fonction des besoins donc c'était se
déploie je crois savoir monsieur le
député mais je mets inconditionnels
pardonnez moi pour cela parce que je ne
veux pas dire les chiffres qui ne serait
pas parfaitement exact mais pour
répondre à votre question je crois
savoir que plus de la moitié des
pharmacies d'officine avait déjà
commandé des tests antigénique ondulant
réalisé en début de semaine et que sa
porte est le chiffre je crois à 2
millions de tests antigénique commandé
par ailleurs nous avions déjà déployé
avant même les recommandations 5
millions de tests antigénique que nous
avions acheté par un stock d'état dans
l'ensemble des hôpitaux et pat de notre
territoire pour mener des
expérimentations grandeur nature donc ce
sera une aide supplémentaire qui ne
remplacera pas le test pc
mais qui permettra de renforcer la
personal dynastique merci beaucoup je
passe la parole à monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre votre audition intervient
presque au terme des travaux de notre
mission en tout cas avec les
prérogatives de la commission denquête
qui lui sont octroyés nous étions
naturellement impatients de vous écouter
écouter les réponses que vous pouvez
apporter à nos questions nous n'avions
pas imaginé losc avec monsieur le
président nous avions plutôt souhaité
que cette audition se fasse au terme de
ces travaux que nous nous trouverions à
nouveau au coeur d'une seconde vague de
la crise sanitaire qui touchent notre
pays et qui naturellement vous mobilise
et mobilise sous votre autorité
toutes les équipes sanitaires dans nos
établissements de santé qu'ils soient
publics ou privés et qui mobilise tous
les acteurs de la santé dans notre pays
et je veux un titre personnel leur dire
bien sûr ma reconnaissance et et mon
soutien dans ces moments qui s'annonce
redoutable le mans éprouvant nous sommes
au coeur de cette seconde vague dont
vous avez rappelé hier soir dans des
termes que nous espérons plus apaisée
cet après midi mais j'en suis convaincu
que le pire était devant nous est-ce que
vous avez je commencerai par là puis
après on aura peut-être des questions
plus techniques que je laisserai mes
collègues poser ces questions aussi
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
quelque part cette seconde vague que le
conseil scientifique avait annoncé
devant nous le 18 juin et que le
professeur flahault début septembre
avait également annoncé
je parle des personnes qui ont été
auditionnées de par nos soins ici est ce
que vous l'avez le sentiment compte tenu
de la gravité qui malheureusement est
avéré qui s'annonce
qu'il ya eu des erreurs dans
l'anticipation une sous-évaluation ou
une sous-estimation du caractère de
gravité de la situation
est ce que il n'ya pas un regret de
votre part d'actions qui n'auraient pas
été mises en oeuvre ou en tout cas dont
l'amplitude n'a pas été suffisamment
forte et je pense en particulier à ce
qui s'est passé lors du conseil de
défense du 11 septembre dernier suivie
d'une conférence de presse du premier
ministre à l'époque
annoncé comme devant diffuser des
mesures restrictives forte puisqu'il y
avait déjà cette inquiétude et qui
finalement a débouché sur quasiment
aucune annonce qui avait surpris ce qui
nous avait surpris qu'ils avaient
surpris les commentateurs et je me
rappelle monsieur le ministre vous avoir
interrogé moi même le 22 septembre en
commission des lois pour pour vous poser
la même question est ce qu'il n'ya pas
finalement un mois de retard dans les
annonces que ce soit sur le couvre-feu
que ce soit préalablement sur la
fermeture de certains établissements
recevant du public ce soit sur le
couvre-feu que ce soit sur le confirmant
le confinement
que ce soit sur la fermeture des
frontières est ce qu'on n'a pas
finalement par rapport à la gravité de
la situation qui s'annonce et que
certains dont certains avaient prévu la
gravité est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu un
manque cruel d'anticipation et également
de préparation
ce rapport te remercie pour votre
question il ne me revient pas il n'est
jamais revenu
le rôle d'émettre quelques prédictions
que ce soit si vous ne m'avez jamais
entendu ni est la possibilité qui
pourrait y avoir une deuxième vague ou
affirmer cela
le temps de cette deuxième vague n'était
pas arrivé mon rôle
il est d'anticiper et de prendre
toujours les décisions qui sont à même
de protéger la population et de préparer
notre système de santé
le conseil scientifique vous l'avez dit
avait évoqué la possibilité d'une
deuxième vague possibilité que nous
avons partagé avec le conseil
scientifique
d'ailleurs dès la première vague comme
étant une hypothèse qui pouvait arriver
je crois même mettre un jour emporté -
qui hier monsieur le rapporteur contre
une prédiction qui avait été fait par un
scientifique disant qu'il n'y aurait
jamais deuxième vague que le virus
mouret quand il fait chaud pendant l'été
je crois que vous pouvez m'en rendre
vous pouvez me rendre cela
quoi qu'il en soit nous avons toujours
anticiper la possibilité qu'il y aurait
une deuxième vague de temps d'ailleurs
que des deuxième vague il y en a eu dans
d'autres pays je ne veux pas vous
rappeler que l'allemagne a mis en place
dès confinement partiel dans certains
secteurs de son territoire alors même
que nous n'avions que nous venions de
terminer notre propre déconfinement je
peux également vous parler des épisodes
épidémiques qui ont émaillé la guyane où
je me suis rendu avec le premier
ministre jean castex et que nous avons
réussi les deux ans l'ensemble des
profils de santé sur place ont réussi à
endiguer
vous parlez de la mayenne où je me suis
également rendu souvenez-vous le mayenne
au début de l'été avec une reprise
épidémique notamment du côté des
abattoirs nous avons déclenché des tests
massive de la population mis en place
des mesures d'isolement de protection et
nous avons réussi là aussi endiguer ce
deuxième ce départ de deuxième vague
potentiel monsieur le rapporteur
il ya eu ensuite le mois la fin du mois
de juillet et le mois d'août
et là vous trouverez assez aisément
nombre d'interventions que j'ai pu faire
estivales expliquant qu' il y avait des
signes d'europe de
deux départs épidémique dans certains
territoires en lien probablement avec de
la convivialité des sorties j'ai parlé
des ruf tome des soirées rooftop dans
certaines villes du sud de la france
et puis avec des indicateurs de pilotage
au quotidien nous n'avons cessé de
suivre que nous n'avons cessé de publier
en toute transparence qui montré que le
virus repartaient chez les jeunes
dans certaines villes du sud et
notamment marseille mais pas que fort de
ce constat nous avons eu un conseil de
défense n'ont pas le 11 septembre
monsieur le rapporteur mais dès le mois
d'août dès le mois d'août dédié au moins
en partie à la situation marseillaise et
qui a donné lieu à des prises de
décision avec l'instauration notamment
d'inde une fermeture anticipée des bars
et restaurants qui avaient été décidés
de mémoire à 23h dans la métropole de
marseille nous étions là bien avant le
11 septembre
monsieur rappaz tanger ainsi sur ce
point est par ailleurs si vous vous
souvenez bien ça ne s'est pas fait sans
douleur
je me suis déplacé à marseille je crois
le 26 août où j'ai rencontré des membres
du secteur hospitalier j'ai rencontré
beaucoup d'élus de la métropole
marseillaise pour leur expliquer ce qui
était en train de se passer nous étions
alors avec deux niveaux d'incidents ce
qui aujourd'hui nous paraît très bien
faible mais qui à l'époque évoqué déjà
une reprise épidémie nous étions
peut-être de l'ordre de 20 pour cent
mille je crois je ne peux pas dire de
bêtises et notamment chez les jeunes à
l'époque comme c'étaient des jeunes qui
étaient touchés
les jeunes font moins de complications
sanitaires il n'y avait donc pas
d'impact sur les hospitalisations et
puis comme il y en a il ya un décalage
de semaine entre le diagnostic et
l'impact sanitaire en termes de recours
à l'hôpital
eh bien rien n'était visible et donc à
l'époque je me souviens très bien sûr le
député y compris dans le champ politique
mais pas que
nombre de personnes ont évoqué
l'hypothèse selon laquelle le virus
aurait muté pour être moins dangereux ou
alors que ce serait des jeunes qui
seraient touchés voir qu'il n'y aurait
pas de deuxième pack possible c'est que
les y'a rien à voir
le couvre-feu qui avait été adoptée à
23h au conseil de défense a ensuite été
porté à minuit et demi et il a fallu
revenir une deuxième fois sur la
situation marseillaise lors d'un autre
conseil de défense je suis plus me
croire je crois m'être déplacé au total
quatre fois à marseille entre le mois
d'août et le
mois d'octobre mais je ne dis pas ça
pour stigmatiser cette ville est
beaucoup trop d'encre a coulé sur les
difficultés que nous aurions eu je dois
dire que j'ai partagé le diagnostic de
la situation avec la maire de marseille
et ce dès la mi-août et avec l'ensemble
des élus d'ailleurs de ces de cette
métropole et de ce territoire et donc il
fallait adapter des mesures qui soit à
la fois comprise par la population
acceptable et efficace nous n'avons eu
de cesse que d'avoir des conseils de
défense et sécurité nationale
abordant la question de la reprise
épidémique du virus et nous n'avons eu
de cesse que de prendre des décisions
pour pouvoir enrayer cette diffusion 7,7
diffusion virale sur l'ensemble du
territoire de façon d'abord
territorialisée différenciez vous vous
en souvenez et ensuite de façon
nationale avec le couvre-feu puis le
nouveau confinement qui a été mis en
place
tout ça pour vous dire monsieur le
rapporteur qu' il n'y aurait la
possibilité d'une deuxième vague aurait
été j'aurais pu l'entendre en termes de
reproches de ou de questions si nous
étions restés les bras croisés à
regarder le virus se développer et se
multiplier ce n'est pas ce qui s'est
passé je laisse chacun juge de d'estimer
si nous avons fait suffisamment
suffisamment tôt etc
je vous dirais juste que quelles que
soient les décisions nous avons pris
depuis le mois de mars était toujours
tout ou trop tôt ou trop tard ont
parfois les deux à la fois
sachez toutefois que nous avons agi en
conséquence les données qui nous était
remonté de manière à toujours garantir
la protection de la population
merci de son ministre mon propos était
était de savoir si personnellement vous
aviez un regret sur ce retard semblerait
c'est les commentaires il faut peut-être
pas toujours les regarder ou les écouter
mais que vous avez toujours prôné des
mesures de protection forte et
personnellement je sors peut-être de mon
rôle de reporter jeu je partage cette
analyse et je suis plutôt de ceux qui
considèrent qu'on n'en fait pas assez
qu'on en fait trop et donc
j'ai toujours soutenu des mesures de
protection mais c'est ça c'est à titre
totalement personnelle et vous ne
trouverez pas dans ceux qui ont contesté
certaines mesures mais justement
semblerait qui est des arbitrages qui a
été pris je crois qu'il ya ce conseil de
défense
il y en a eu avant sans doute mais je
crois qu'elle a lieu en septembre sauf
erreur de ma part
est-ce que là il n'y a pas eu des
décisions que vous souteniez
personnellement vous peut-être plus
protectrice peut-être plus restrictive
qui n'ont pas été adoptées et qui nous
aurait pu aurait pu marquer une
anticipation plus forte sur la sur
l'avancée du virus et puis voilà c'était
cette précision ce cas vos questions et
je voudrais vous interroger avant de
passer la parole le président du pas sa
parole mais peut-être là dessus puis
après je voudrais vous poser une
question sur la sur les tests j'entends
un attachement de votre part un conseil
de défense et de sécurité nationale en
particulier je ne sais plus ce chiffre
en tête mais je crois qu'il ya une bonne
trentaine si ce n'est plus déjà sur la
question du cornât virus vous savez
monsieur rapporteur que ce qui se dit au
sein d'un conseil de défense et sécurité
nationale relève de la défense et de la
sécurité nationale n'est pas d'une
commission denquête mêmes parlementaires
et c'est pas un manque de respect que de
dire cela je vais nommant vous dire une
chose je en étant très à l'aise j'ai
toujours été très à l'aise très en phase
avec les décisions qui ont été prises
que ce soit en conseil de défense ou
ailleurs depuis début de cette vague
épidémique depuis le début de set en
demi
il n'y a pas une fois où comme ministre
des solidarités et de la santé je me
suis senti en décalage ou en porte à
faux vis à vis d'une décision qui aurait
été actée et je suis reconnaissant à
l'ensemble de mes collègues ministres au
premier ministre au président de la
république pour la capacité d'écouté de
dialogue de discussion des changes
je suis reconnaissant à l'ensemble de la
communauté scientifique aux experts des
différentes agences d'état ou
indépendantes qui ont toujours guidé
avec soin et avec bienveillance et avec
qualité l'ensemble des décisions que
nous avons prises
donc de ce point de vue là monsieur le
rapporteur je vous tranquillise quant à
savoir si je peux avoir des regrets sur
telle ou telle décision ou sur telle ou
telle mesure je me ferai peut-être une
pirouette mais l'heure n'est pas de
regrets l'heure est à apprendre en
marchant à anticiper à comprendre à
accompagner à s'interroger à se ré
interroger et à se réinterroger encore
sans rien fixé jamais dans le marbre
tant les connaissances scientifiques
sont amenés à évoluer en matière
épidémique
je rappellerai que le coronavirus est un
phénomène naturel que c'est un virus que
les virus préexistait à l'homme sur
terre
non pas que je trouve qu'il toit d'une
bonne compagnie ce n'est pas ce que je
dis et je dis qu'il ya toujours eu des
épidémies qu'il y en aura toujours
avec des virus qui peut peut-être d'une
férocité exceptionnels comme celui que
nous connaissons ou des virus beaucoup
plus panneaux qui passe sans faire de
vagues que sais tu ne l'as pas entraîner
une situation de catastrophe naturelle
ce que nous connaissons aujourd'hui est
que face à cela nous devons rester
humbles
nous devons rester humbles apprendre les
uns des autres et un point qui est
important que je voudrais souligner à ce
stade aussi de l'audition c'est que nous
apprenons beaucoup les uns des autres
avec les différents experts et acteurs
étrangers
il n'y a pas une semaine qui s'écoule
sans que soient amenés à échanger avec
des homologues
la semaine dernière c'était avec mon
homologue québécois hier avec mon
homologue allemand et trois jours je
crois avec mon homologue espagnol avec
les italiens les suisses nous nous
appelons nous échangeons les
informations nous échangeons les données
nous partageons les constats nous
partageons les stratégies nous nous
appuyons les uns sur les autres
nous avançons et progressons ensemble il
en va d'ailleurs de la même manière pour
ce confinement et le déroulé des mesures
de freinage qui ont été mises en place
sur le territoire qui sont de plus en
plus analogue les unes aux autres quel
que soit le pays où on regarde
y compris d'ailleurs à l'autre bout du
monde qu'il s'agisse de l'australie pour
ce qui concerne le l'hémisphère sud où
les pays du nord certains pays du nord
de l'europe ou encore asiatiques
c'est le président si vous me toiser une
série de questions sur les tests il ya
la fois les les tests du début de crise
sur les quinze premiers jours de mars
juste avant le confie demander si dès le
17 mars
notre pays a réalisé je crois un peu
moins de quinze mille tests alors que
l'allemagne dans la même période ont
réalisé 250 milles la question de cette
capacité de tester est au coeur de la
diffusion du virus
on a auditionné plusieurs acteurs qui
ont remis en cause les stratégies qui
avait été adoptée qui en tout cas plus
que remettre en cause les stratégies ont
dénoncé des lourdeurs des blocages
administratifs qui ont conduit notre
pays à environ un mois de retard dans le
déploiement d'une capacité de tests
suffisante
c'est vrai sur les laboratoires
vétérinaires départementaux les
présidents départementaux ont saisi
autour de la mi mars
la décision de débloquer l'action de ces
laboratoires intervient je crois le 6
avril c'est vrai pour les laboratoires
privés
nous en avons auditionné tous les
représentants qui eux mêmes ont évoqué
ce mois de retard et une forme dospital
au centrisme
c'est vrai également pour la
mobilisation de certains laboratoires
publics hors centre hospitalier
universitaire je sais que dans mon
département
il ya eu un débat sur certains
laboratoires publics de recherche avec
une forme de conflit avec des
laboratoires hospitaliers
le préfet lui même avait dit que il
essayer de régler ces tensions avec des
blocages administratifs
on les a on les a constaté donc comment
expliquer ces retards comment expliquer
ces lenteurs de décisions ses lourdeurs
sur la sur la première vague et puis sur
la seconde vague
cette fois nous avions le nombre de
tests suffisant que vous aviez évoqué
monsieur le ministre qui était au rendez
vous
mais le délai de résultats de ces tests
a été tellement longs qu'ils ont
quasiment rendu inopérant ces tests
puisque entre les délais de prise de
rendez vous et les délais de résultats
la durée de contagiosité des personnes
potentiellement atteintes dépassé les 7
jours et donc a pu favoriser la
propagation du virus est complètement
mettre en échec la stat la stratégie que
vous aviez annoncé tester tracé isolé et
ce qui a conduit au fait que la
situation est aujourd'hui totalement je
crois et je pense reprendre vos propos
totalement de hors de contrôle
voilà pourquoi il ya eu sur la première
vague est sur la deuxième et c'est
peut-être encore plus grave sur la
deuxième cette difficulté sur les tests
qui sont au coeur ces difficultés sont
au coeur de l'accélération de la
propagation du virus ou en tout cas sont
au coeur de notre capacité à freiner ou
voir à interrompre sa propagation
alors plusieurs éléments de réponse
parce qu'il m'avait posé plusieurs
questions sur les vestes
d'abord la question des tests de
dépistage à réaliser à grande échelle
c'est à dire au delà d'une certaine
population les cas graves les soignants
les cas très douteux n'a jamais été
évoquée ni en janvier ni en février dans
le cadre des échanges internationaux que
ce soit avec les pays du g7 où le
conseil epsco du 13 février ou dans les
échanges entre la ministre de l'époque
et le directeur général de l'om est et
drôle concernant l'om est la première
recommandation de l'om s sur la
réalisation des tests en laboratoire
date du 12 février 2020 j'étais donc pas
encore ministre puis du 2 mars et enfin
du 21 mars elles sont d'ailleurs
purement technique ces recommandations
oms et ne donne aucune stratégie de
dépistage et n'indiquent pas qu'il faut
tester d'autres personnes que les seules
personnes malades
ça c'est un premier point qui est
important c'est dans une allocation dans
une allocution du 16 mars 2020 le
directeur général de l'om l1
t'as testé massivement il le dit alors
car beaucoup de pays ne sont même pas
encore dotés de capacités à tester donc
à identifier les cas suspects et n'ont
pas accès à la bcr et l'appel de tedros
à l'époque consiste à dire au pays
tester tester tester
il faut que vous puissiez diagnostic et
si vous ne diagnostique et pas vous
n'aurez même pas si vous avez
coronavirus qui circulent dans votre
pays
nous n'avions pas de notion
janvier-février de la moindre
recommandation de le cdc non plus
s'agissant des stratégies de dépistage
différente de ce que nous faisions à
l'époque maintenant des chiffres les
tests pcr ont été disponibles en france
à partir du 27 janvier développement
d'un test diagnostique rapide par
l'institut pasteur permettant de donner
un résultat en quelques heures
montée en puissance ensuite de ces tests
qui a été rapide cinq laboratoires
équipés
le 31 janvier 20 laboratoires le 21
février 48 3 laboratoires équipés le 7
mars à partir du 6 avril les
laboratoires autre que de biologie
médicale notamment les laboratoires
départementaux vétérinaires ont été
autorisés à réaliser des tests vous
poser la question de savoir si ça a pris
du temps ou plutôt pourquoi j'aurais
pris du temps d'autoriser laboratoires
départementaux
j'ai beaucoup aimé la réponse de
l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe lorsque vous lui avez posé la
question et je vais je vais aller assez
dans ce sens il ya parfois des
changements réglementaires que vous
pouvez faire rapidement
je vous donne un exemple lorsqu'il a
fallu autoriser les pharmaciens
d'officine à fabriquer leur gel
hydroalcoolique la main n'a pas tremblé
violemment n'a jamais tremblé mais le
motorisé très vite d'ailleurs été
soulignée y compris par des
parlementaires de l'opposition à
l'époque de manière quand il a fallu
plafonner le prix des masques nous
l'avons fait c'est quelque chose qui
n'apportent pas de conséquences en tout
cas dont on estimait que les
conséquences étaient extrêmement faibles
sur la santé humaine
s'agissant de l'autorisation de
laboratoire qui n'ont jamais fait de
dépistage chez des humains qui
fonctionnait pour beaucoup d'entre eux
par système de pooling c'est à dire en
mettant plusieurs prélèvements en même
temps dans une machine pour voir si un
des prélèvements étaient positifs il a
fallu un peu de temps d'expertisé je
bouge je ne
j'ai très faim la pierre sur les
services et les différentes autorités
qui ont été saisis pour cela parce que
le travail a été fait dans des raids
dans des délais rapides toujours est il
que le 6 avril
ils ont été autorisés selon s'agissant
de la capacité les tests pcr nous étions
à 2000 tests par jour fin février début
mars
cinq mille tests pcr par jour début
avril les laboratoires se sont enquis de
pouvoir acheter des machines pour faire
des tests pcr ce sont des grosses
machines coûteuses qui viennent de
l'étranger avec une demande mondiale qui
est très forte
nous avons soutenu les répartitions de
ces de ces machines en achetant nous
mêmes des machines publiques mises en
place dans certains hôpitaux et
laboratoires ont acheté massivement des
machines nous les avons accompagnées et
encouragées en garantissant un tarif
pour le test en leur garantissant qu'un
grand nombre de tests réalisés dans la
durée nous sommes donc passés au moment
du décompte final
à cinquante mille tests par jour
quarante à cinquante mille tests par
jour vous voyez qu'entre avril entre
avril et début mai nous avons multiplié
par dix le nombre de tests nous avons
ensuite augmenter le nombre de tests
réalisés pendant l'été ce n'était pas
que nous étions pas capable de faire
davantage de tests et qu'il n'y avait
plus entre guillemets de challans c'est
à dire qu'il y avait moins de gens
voulant se faire dépister le virus
circule très peu que de capacité avec
liszt et d'ailleurs nous étions à moins
de 1% des tests réalisés qui était
positif 99 % des gens qui se détestaient
et est donc négatif pour le coc vite
vous posez ensuite nous avons décidé
d'ailleurs et c'est une tous les pays
n'ont pas fait de la même de la même
manière nous avons décidé de garantir
l'accès pour tous les français au test
avec une prise en charge à 100% par
l'assurance maladie ce qui fait pour
quatre ans n a eu à débourser le moindre
centime pour pouvoir se faire tester par
préfère et ce depuis le début de
l'épidémie ce qu'on dit pas beaucoup
il ya beaucoup de pays qui ont mis en
place des systèmes de test avec un reste
à charge pour les personnes qui parfois
pouvait peser et crée des inégalités
dans l'accès en accès aux tests
nous sommes désormais passés à 2
millions de tests par semaine c'est un
effort sans précédent dans l'histoire
des luttes épidémie d'abord pays j'en
remercie les techniciens de laboratoire
et laborantins les biologistes mais
aussi toutes les personnes que j'ai
autorisé par arrêté successifs à faire
des prélèvements des infirmières les
étudiants en santé les secouristes à
chaque fois qu'il a fallu lever des
barrières pour permettre aux
laboratoires de tester davantage nous
l'avons
c'est une période à la rentrée scolaire
où il eut un bouchon très clair sur
l'accès aux tests
vous avez raison de souligner nous
l'avons d'ailleurs souligné nous mêmes
un bouchon qui s'est formée assez vite
que nous avions des indicateurs de suivi
des rendus de résultats tout allait très
bien et d'un coup par les délais se sont
allongés les causes sont connues
monsieur le rapporteur beaucoup de gens
retrouver le chemin du travail
il voulait être testés avant de rentrer
dans leurs usines l'entreprise en
vacances
beaucoup voulaient se faire tester avant
de rentrer à l'université et surtout
beaucoup de gens revenaient de voyage ou
continuer de se déplacer dans le cadre
de leurs vacances où il aurait était
exigée de produire un test dont vous
avez hélas hélas une masse de la
population extrêmement importante qui a
voulu se faire tester au même moment au
même moment je pourrais je tiens à
souligner monsieur le reporter que la
france n'a pas fait exception en la
matière tels que même les pays qui
testait ils sont pas nombreux plus que
nous à l'époque ont rencontré les mêmes
difficultés
l'angleterre a été obligé d'envoyer des
camions de tests de prélèvement paix
serre jusqu'en italie pour pouvoir
rattraper le retard qu'ils avaient été
pris
c'était également des retards qu'ils
aient pu atteindre plusieurs jours en
allemagne
donc dans l'ensemble des pays au même
moment la même période et pour les mêmes
raisons pour les mêmes raisons
ça va pas dire que c'est acceptable mais
ça veut dire qu'il n'y avait pas de
solution permettant de faire
différemment à ce moment là les antilles
génie clairement seront une aide puisque
si un nouveau une période avec une très
forte concentration de population qui
veut se faire tester les tests
antigénique permettront d'éviter qu'il y
ait des délais qui soient qu'ils soient
importants jour et îles cook en cours du
mois de septembre et ensuite au mois
d'octobre
nous avons non seulement augmenter la
capacité de tests augmenter le nombre de
tests réalisés nous avons fait chuter
les délais dans des tables est
d'ailleurs assez assez rapide monsieur
le rapporteur vous tirer une conclusion
que je ne suis incapable de tenir moi
même et pour laquelle j'émets quelques
doutes
vous dites dans votre question ce qui ne
rend pas forcément ce ne n'est pas
forcément d'accord c'est parce qu'il ya
eu des retards que la vague épidémique
est parti sur rapporteur je pourrais
vous montrez chiffres à l'appui on
pourrait regarder les courbes ensemble
et vous verrez que les courbes ont pris
une ascension encore plus importante une
fois que les délais de tests étaient à
nouveau extrêmement courtes où l'on
pouvait se faire tester dans des bonnes
conditions
y'a pas forcément une carte corrélation
entre les deux au fond
si vous deviez en avoir une preuve
supplémentaire regarder à l'étranger y
compris les pays qui n'ont pas rencontré
de difficultés à ce moment là dans leur
accès aux tests ont vu un départ
épidémique je pense par exemple à
l'italie qui a vu son débit l'émir
partir il ya moins d'un mois donc bien
après la rentrée de septembre et qui
n'étaient pas en difficulté pour tester
ou encore la suisse qui est un modèle en
matière de testing et de contacts racing
et qui en l'espace de quelques jours a
dû l'ascension de cas très importante
donc encore une fois le l'accès au test
est important c'est un outil de l'ugtg
le tracking est important c'est un outil
de lutte aussi contre l'épidémie ne
croyons pas une seconde ne croyait
vraiment je le dis sincèrement parce que
c'est important pour l'avenir
ne croyant pas une seconde qu'il y
aurait une solution matérielle humaine
capable à elle seule des vies terre
départ épidémique et le rugby russe
recommence à circuler que les conditions
de circulation sont réunis c'est au coup
je passe la parole à merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je ne
reviens pas sur sur le feuilleton
polémique des masques et de la question
de l'eprus vous connaissez mon point de
vue donc je voudrais vous poser d'autres
questions à savoir une première question
c'est est-ce que vous avez répondu
présent à l'invitation entre guillemets
de la fédération hospitalière privée qui
a proposé environ 4000 lits de
réanimation avec leurs soignants pour
pouvoir compléter l'ensemble public
deuxièmement que pouvez-vous me dire sur
la surmortalité invisible qui est
occultée par le cos vide 19 je pense au
cancer je pense aux maladies
cardiovasculaires et autres et on a des
certificats de décès que j'ai pu
constater dans dans la mairie où
j'apparais j'appartiens à savoir des
personnes très âgées qui sont décédés
marqué que 8 19
or il n'y a jamais de crever 19 ses
passions
donc c'est le médecin qui a marqué que 8
19 centres voilà on ne sait pas pourquoi
mais il ya une
surmortalité qui existe dans les
certificats médicaux j'ai posé la
question à monsieur salomon mais il m'a
dit qu'il regarderait ça en détail
je voudrais aussi vous poser une
question sur vous avait parlé de la
campagne de tests
il ya un pays qui a donné des résultats
très positifs en europe en en testant
plus de 50% de la population
c'est la finlande la finlande qui a très
très peu de décès et de contamination
donc faut-il augmenter encore la
campagne de dépistage en allant vers la
vère près de 50 % de notre population je
pense que ce serait nécessaire enfin la
dernière question
j'ai les tests antigénique j'ai voulu
engager pendant un ccas local parce
qu'il y avait une personne qui était
testé positif la rs m'a refusé d'engager
les tests antigénique demandant le test
pcr
ce qui bloque un peu le ccas donc il
faudrait que chacun voit midi à sa porte
et puissent donner des réponses et enfin
une réponse que je souhaite vous posez
mais vous pourrez probablement pas y
répondre je déposais edouard philippe
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre
rapport critique du général liseret qui
avait rendu un rapport proposé par le
pôle ex premiers ministres du rapport de
la fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers et enfin d'un ministre
de la santé qui était sur votre siège il
ya quelques années
vous savez lequel elle qui a édité un
livre assez critique sur la gestion de
vous se récrie voulait le nom philippe
douste-blazy
non mais savoir quel aux réponses nous
apporter à ces rapports qui sont assez
critiques mais c'est pas votre gestion
c'est celle depuis le début de la crise
c'est-à-dire depuis octobre 2019 2020
merci parce qu'on était inquiet pour les
gens qui nous écoutent on s'est dit on
sait pas s'il va pouvoir répondre à une
question sur quelqu'un qui avait
peut-être écrire la provence
qui sait pour qui donc c'était si
monsieur d'or je passe la parole à
monsieur madoff merci monsieur le
président merci monsieur le ministre
d'abord ils vous le savez rappelé
l'objet de la commission denquête c'est
une mission qui vise à évaluer l'action
du gouvernement pour comprendre ce qui
s'est passé et pour en tirer des
conclusions des conclusions utiles c'est
notre devoir et c'est aussi la réalité
je suis sûr que vous êtes prêts à
l'entendre cette travail il est d'autant
plus nécessaire que vous l'avez évoqué
vous-même était connue depuis juin au
moins la possibilité d'une seconde vague
aujourd'hui on évoque même dans le
rapport récent du conseil scientifique
la possibilité d'une troisième vague et
pourquoi et pourquoi pas d'autres
vous nous avez appelé à l humilité et
nous le concevons c'est une situation
qui est inédite qui est extrêmement
compliqué mais ça nous interdit pas
d'être exigeant dans la compréhension de
ce qui c'est de ce qui s'est passé
surtout en plein coeur d'une seconde
vague dont on nous dit qu'elle sera plus
importante que la première
je voudrais revenir pour approfondir
quelques questions que monsieur ciotti
vous a déjà posé sur la stratégie des
tests
la stratégie tester tracé isolés dont le
comité scientifique a parlé en disant
que c'était un relatif échec
d'autres ont été plus plus plus dur
puisque dominique e.costa viola a évoqué
un déconfinement un déconfinement raté
la question qui se pose c'est est ce que
vous pensez pas que décisions qui
avaient été prises fin juillet de
permettre l'accès aux thèses sans
ordonnance pour tous un contenu d'une
certaine manière à court circuiter les
professionnels de ville à saturer
laboratoire a généré des délais très
longs ce que vous avez évoquées au total
a paralysé la stratégie prescrites par
l'om est celle que vous avez vous prévu
de contester tracé isolé c'est à dire
mettre aussi en échec le contact racing
vous avez dit qu'au fond il n'y a pas de
lien et pas de corrélation entre
l'embolie et le départ de l'épidémie
du coup on se demande si vous avez une
explication sur le départ et pique nique
et puis est ce que n'a pas manqué à la
stratégie de massification le texte une
stratégie de politique de tête c'est à
dire en termes de priorisation qui
priorise et en termes de délais de
restitution des résultats
pour les intégrer
safe small and response
accès
you and i want you tube
choqué par de skene de sélection russe
trust lth diane barras est une arme du
crime
les all blacks access manager 9 mars
[Musique]
enjoy
l'absence d'avocat l'activité